en los vídeos pasados hicimos bastante
talacha matemática que quizá este
encaste pero logramos un resultado
sensacional obtuvimos una fórmula para
la pendiente y la ordenada al origen de
la recta regresión que mejor se ajusta
cuando mides el error a través del
cuadrado de la distancia a esa línea y
nuestra fórmula es la voy a escribir
aquí para que la tengamos presente la
pendiente es igual a la media de las x
por la media y las diez menos la media
de las xy es y no te preocupes se ve
confuso esto pero vamos a hacer un
ejemplo a continuación para que te quede
claro todo esto dividido entre la media
y las x al cuadrado menos la media de
las x cuadradas y si esto será diferente
a como lo ves en la clase estadística o
en tu libro de texto donde la puedes ver
invertida si multiplicas el numerador y
el denominador por menos 1 entonces esta
expresión se puede escribir como la
media de x es menos la media y las x por
la media y la yes dividido entre la
media de las x al cuadrado menos la
media de x l
y estas expresiones son equivalentes
estás multiplicando el numerador y el
denominador por menos 1 que es lo mismo
multiplicar por 1 toda la expresión y
por supuesto el valor que tú tengas para
m lo puedes sustituir en esta expresión
para obtener el valor de b to be va a
ser igual a la media de leyes menos tú m
voy a ponerle en amarillo para que quede
claro es el valor que encontraste de m
- m por la media de las x menos c m x
la media de las equis y es todo lo que
necesitamos de hecho vamos a ponerlo en
práctica supongamos que tenemos tres
puntos y voy a cerciorarse de que estos
puntos no sean con lineales pues de otra
manera no sería interesante así es que
déjame dibujar tres puntos por aquí así
que digamos que uno de los puntos es el
punto 1,2
12 aquí tenemos el punto 1 2 y luego
otro punto digamos el punto
aquí tenemos el punto 21 pongamos un
tercer punto hagamos algo loco con estos
puntos el punto 3 punto 3
34 no no mejor vamos a ponerlo por acá
para que quepa en nuestro pantalla
entonces más bien va a ser el punto 443
aquí tenemos el punto 4,3 estos son
nuestros 3 puntos y lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar la línea de regresión
que mejor se ajusta y sospechamos que
esta línea se va a ver algo así
ya veremos realmente cómo se ve
aplicando nuestras fórmulas que ya hemos
probado una buena manera de empezar ese
entonces calcular estos valores para
luego sustituirlos en las ecuaciones
bien cuál es la media de las x la media
de las x es igual a 1 más y voy a usar
el mismo color que tienen en los puntos
uno más dos más
/ / voy a usar un color neutral para
esto dividido entre 3 y cuánto nos da
esto 124 entre 3 es igual a 7 tercios
ahora cuál es la media de las 10 la
media de la 10
es igual a voy a usar un color neutral
la media ley es es igual
2 más 1
más
/
entre 3 2 1 363 esto es igual a 6
tercios lo cual es igual a 2
dos más uno más tres en tres es igual a
dos
ok vamos ahora a calcular la media de
las equis y es la media de la se
quisiese es igual
nuestra primera xy es 1 por dos el
producto de 1 por 2 más
el producto de dos por uno más el
producto de cuatro por tres
todo esto dividido son tres puntos
entonces dividido entre 3 1 por 2 es 22
por uno es 2 4 por 3 es 12 12 212 es 16
sobre 3 16 tercios lo tengo bien 2 más 2
más 12 16 tercios y está bien entonces
nos falta ahora la media de las x al
cuadrado la media de las x cuadradas es
igual aquí tenemos 1 al cuadrado 1 al
cuadrado más tenemos 2 al cuadrado más 2
al cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado más 4 al
cuadrado dividido entre son 3 puntos
nuevamente esto es dividido entre 3 y
esto nos va a dar un al cuadro es uno
más 2 al cuadrado 45 más 4 al cuadrado
más 16 es igual a 21
perfecto un número entero 7 vamos a
encontrar entonces la m y la b así la
pendiente la media óptima de la recta de
regresión es igual a la media de las x
la media de las x es igual a 7 tercios
por la media de las íes que es igual a 2
menos la media de las equis y es que es
igual a 16 tercios sobre la media de las
x al cuadrado que es igual a
siete tercios al cuadrado
menos
la media de las equis cuadradas que es
igual a 7 tenemos aquí que hacer un poco
de aritmética estoy tentado a sacar mi
calculadora pero voy a resistir la
tentación siempre es bueno mantener las
expresiones en fracciones entonces aquí
tenemos siete tercios por dos es igual a
catorce tercios menos dieciséis tercios
sobre siete tercios al cuadrado es 49
novenos menos el 7 lo voy a transformar
en novenos sería 7 por 9 63 entonces
sería menos 63 novenos
entonces nuestro numerador resulta 14
tercios menos 63 y es igual a menos dos
tercios sobre 49 novenos menos 33
novenos 49 menos 63 esto es igual a
menos 14 novenos y esto va a ser igual a
menos dos tercios por 914 abós menos 9
14 a vos esto es igual a simplificamos
aquí esto va a ser positivo para empezar
dividimos entre 31 dividimos entre 33
dividimos entre 21 dividimos entre 27 es
igual a 3 séptimos no está mal
nuestra pendiente es igual a 3 séptimos
podemos regresar entonces para calcular
la ordenada al origen la orden al origen
aquí tenemos nuestra fórmula la orden a
del origen me va a ser igual a la media
de las yes que es igual a 2 menos
la pendiente que acabamos de calcular
que es 3 séptimos 3 séptimos
la media de las x la media las x aquí la
tenemos que es siete tercios
3 séptimos y 7 tercios se simplifican en
1 entonces la orden al origen va a ser
dos menos 1 es igual a 1 ya tenemos
entonces la ecuación de la recta la
ecuación de la recta regresión es igual
a igual a m la pendiente que calculamos
aquí como 3 séptimos 3 séptimos por
equis más la ordenada el origen que
acabamos de calcular que es igual a 1 y
ya hemos terminado ya hemos terminado
vamos a graficar la la ordenada al
origen es 1
aquí tenemos es ordenada y la pendiente
es 3 séptimos es decir por cada 7 de
avance tenemos 3 de elevación u otra
manera de pensarlo es por cada tres y
medio de avance tenemos un medio de
elevación aquí tenemos otro punto de la
recta así que esta recta titula gráficas
y la buena será manu no va a ser tan
exacta pasaría por aquí
de hecho no va a pasar por este punto
déjame corregirlo para que note una
impresión errónea que pasa por aquí
vamos a corregirlo un poco se va a ver
algo así y para esta línea hemos
mostrado que esta fórmula minimiza el
cuadro de las distancias de cada uno de
estos puntos a esa línea en fin desde mi
perspectiva esto es realmente
sensacional